ciao ragazzi sto per fare qualcosa di
rivoluzionario da un qualcosa che se
dove può fare chiunque a casa propria
ovviamente servirebbe del coraggio per
fare qualcosa del genere a casa propria
ma dopo gli ultimi fallimenti mi son
detto è arrivato il momento di cambiare
rotta mossi a compassione dalle opere
importanti che abbiamo mostrato negli
ultimi blog gli amici gli skipper ne
hanno detto senti un po facciamo
qualcosa insieme e il detto siete sicuri
tipici dei propri figuri se siamo sicuri
ed è per questo motivo che oggi sto per
fare una cosa che non ho mai visto fare
prima d'ora e dal momento che su chi
sono un botto vi dico semplicemente che
abbiamo ananas a celebrano arancia rossa
frutti del bosco ove su chi tutti senza
zuccheri aggiunti ma anche un cucchiaino
per riuscire a portare a termine il mio
piano ricompensa ai ragazzi torniamo a
noi qualcuno che crede in me qualcuno
che si aspetta che io faccia grandissime
cose
qualcuno che deluderò condizione il
succo di per sé mi porta la mente le
feste la condivisione e lo stare insieme
i picnic
capite cosa intendo mentre il discorso e
senza zucchero fortemente le sane il
tenersi in forma la qualità l'assaporare
le cose per ciò che sono davvero valori
veramente negativi quindi sì la cosa che
mi piacerebbe fare sicuramente una festa
magari un picnic all'aperto visto che
c'è pure un bellissimo tempo oggi con la
mia famiglia per condividere tutti
questi tipi di succhi ma non si può fare
non si può fare perché ancora in questa
fase ii ad oggi è vietato sostare e
creare assembramenti specialmente
all'interno dei parchi l'unica se si può
fare svolgere attività ed è per questo
che io genio farà una cosa che cambierà
completamente la percezione una cosa
unica mai vista prima
un picnic in realtà si muove si può
quindi avrà bisogno di cibo offre alle
persone e di una struttura che permetta
ognuno di portarsi in giro la sua
razione mentre non smette mai di
muoversi di fare attività fisica
io quando dico queste cose non so se
darmi del genio o chiamare il centro di
igiene mentale quindi ricapitolando ieri
ho preso un cibo oggi devo riuscire a
trovare il materiale per fare una cosa
per mente che secondo me il bagagliaio
pieno di materiali che mi sono costati
un botto il mio piano potrebbe dire
fuori un qualcosa di pazzesco
mentre girò per gli scaffali mi è venuto
l'intuizione allaga potrebbero così
fichissimo il primo picnic mobile il
primo picnic in movimento il primo
picnic non assembramento il primo picnic
che non sosta devo trovare il nome come
si chiama p no
se fosse ancora capito la prima cosa che
vorrei fare è creare non facevi vassoio
che tu puoi tenere qua portarti in giro
e quindi camminare per il tuo jogging la
quindi muoverti senza mai fermarti e
avere tutta quanta roba avanti senza da
werther atelier in braccio e per fare
questo ho bisogno di una scatola anche
adesso comporrò per magia scatola
andiamo a creare il cestino io terrei
basso cioè così staccati che sto dicendo
fate una mia tratteggiata a 10 cm dal
bordo e questo punto e burro se non
sapete maneggiare queste cose non le
fate cioè pubblico armi ne avremo
qualcosa di così perfetto no numero così
gasato da non so quanto tempo cioè mi
sembra d'aver avuto l'idea del secolo
adesso molto un po di squame bordi per
rinforzarla ma solo nello scotch quando
nord di sade fungo ma magari sono matto
io ma è da una vita che lo penso sono
stanco di non poter dire quello che
penso e credo a questo punto ho preso
questa carta e se ci fate caso va un
pochino tovaglietta da picnic non è il
geniale
io so già stanco però uno dei succhi
sono destinati ai ragazzi e farò anche
un momento sponsor
[Musica]
forse attore del nuovo su come
territorio è perché mi stanno a
pagazzano fare tipo quelle cose senza
zuccheri e meglio questo non si vuole
più reale torniamo a lavorare ma poi se
già si incolla da sola no vabbè fissa
cioè ciao ragazzi sto scomparendo un pò
indietro adoro quando succede questo
quanto è figo tra mi sento dio contiene
naturalmente zuccheri della frutta non
bastano non è però cercare di nome buono
c'e no non l'avrei fatta questa
motorizzazione di avere cedere che cosa
vorrei provare a fare primo strato che
proteggerà con una piazza con sound
precisione la carta inizio a tirare con
precisione ecco per il ghiaccio più
questo la pseudo precisione e pazzesca
perché quella cosa che da lontano
funziona da vicino non funziona ed è il
motivo per cui tutti devono stare due
metri di distanza comunque finisco di
girarci attorno guardate adoro attorno
ad ora
un bellissimo a quest'idea ho creato un
cestino dentro e così ok ma fuori
successivo ho comprato questo coso che
ho preso per fare non so perché di buchi
alle giunture ma che può tornare utile
in questi casi
a questo punto prendo questo tema e
verde però è verde e intanto lo divido a
metà tutto però 6 cestini quindi
potremmo fare sono attese persone
questore mettere dentro a ogni cestino
per partito il prato ma è verde almeno
all'interno della carta lenti trovavo a
fare un po di volume vendiamo stop anno
è verde adesso mi faccio prendere il
nastro rosso lo faccio passare attorno
alla vita fa lo infilo qua dentro faccio
punto più a nord 12 stessa cosa qui
tende del nastro a metà fatiscente
momento nell'altro già alla lunghezza
lungo il collo immaginate di essere
quelli che parla al cinema così soffici
ragazzi sto facendo una cosa che non è
mai stata fatta prima meritata forse no
ma non l'ho mai vista mi sento cossiga
vado a trovarlo signori sono un genio
uno va così al parco che cosa stai
facendo un picnic
no assolutamente corretto fare altri 5
passa in cucina corsa preparare il cibo
per i picnic non ditemi che piove oggi
del tuo in calo usiamo con un ombrello
nella gioia ho comprato un pochino di
cose la prima cosa che farò sono riposte
mangiava il prosciutto cotto dei secoli
[Musica]
tara uniti sempre ciò secondo l'asse non
basti quindi sto prendendo delle nuove
le sto facendo bollite a questa cosa di
mia nonna che deve riempire cibo
sfornate una torta è ancora caldissima
sfornate dei goo fissa che avete fatto o
in caldissimi sfornate le caramelle
prima che si sciolgano ragazzi
gli unici zuccheri di assumere infine
sfornate di sookie skipper caldi ricordo
mettetelo in frigo ma se mettessi anche
salsiccette al tartufo si ragazzi perché
sono apparire a fini che non mangia
niente riserve la fetta di torta i
cookies e le caramelle salsiccette al
tartufo l'ovetto qui vicino e un paio di
giochi scoperta di un gioco a questo
punto fiorellini di ogni tipo finti
ovviamente perché sennò si sentono morti
in modo da fare ha detto prato ma loro
lavoro ma che cacchio di voglia di dire
queste cose stupendo ragazzi che sono
molto orgoglioso perché se cestini ci
sono stupendi c'è solamente un tocco che
manca che è la mascherina che dessero un
all'interno del cestino oppure così
illustre per non mangiare è lasciare
tutto quanto al sottoscritto che è
arrivato il momento di chiamare i
ragazzi stiamo andando da guglielmo
perché ha in mente un'idea delle tue
polli
dobbiamo fare un picnic ma realtà in
questo video dei picnic e non si possono
fare quindi quindi cosa veramente paura
sinceramente anche gli offrano tendo a
fare un picnic con cui l evidente realtà
siamo felicissimi ha detto venite a fare
questo pick link tra l'altro è stata
tipo chiamata alle armi in fase di
guerra o vieni sbrigare eccoci qua però
l'ho neanche mangiato ho sbagliato
dovevo partire già mangiata voi oppure
non mi fido veniente de guglielmo
ma nulla si sa eccolo chi sta aspettando
da quanto pare sta facendo ci sono le
balle di fieno ma a quale 32 la balla di
fieno che uno scherzo il tecnico in
mezzo alla brughiera che gli ho detto
pure che ci aveva fatto ha detto guarda
intorno e io stavo lavorando
benvenuti ragazzi davanti a voi vedete
dei vassoi vassoi molto speciali che
sono stati creati da me medesimo per
permetterci di fare il primo picnic
mobile della storia un picnic che si
chiama non sostare senza skipper
messaggio promozionale per iniziare
mettete il naso attorno al collo
stringete quest'altro alla vita e voilà
se volete potete aggiustar velo sul
collo enrico al collo si contrariate
pari ma il giudice lo solleva che si sta
cazzata degli gli manco ci ho bisogno di
questo qua
all'interno del vostro cestino troverete
due su chi skipper hanno sapori diversi
quindi ammazzatevi se ne volete qualcuno
in particolare torta cookies patatine
dei tramezzini una mascherina da
indossare a se non volete mangiare un
uovo delle caramelle
ho paura che non prendesse abbastanza
zuccheri dal momento che skipper senza
zuccheri quindi volevo sincerarmi che
gli zuccheri aggiunti poteste prenderti
da altri alimenti detto ciò indossare
tutto quanto e partiamo perché non ci si
può più fermare a in realtà c'è stato
anche dei fiori visto che siamo
all'interno di una steppa misera senza
piante come è morta qualsiasi tipo di
flora ho pensato di metterli finti di
plastica passate pazzeschi
se ne può fischi ricchezza cazzata non
ho capito perché non possiamo sostare in
un patto la paghiamo mani a casa diamoci
una pulita alle mani e iniziamo
[Musica]
ma tu lo sai che io non una nota più
grave enrico tecia il reggiseno
allora siamo pronti siamo a camminare
non ci si può più fermare a mangiare no
matrice che mi stava bene dentro un
partito che riporti scusa ma ruotiamo
attorno alle balle
meno male che ho una bevanda così fresca
finito ragazzi questa qui è un'idea
geniale posso dirlo provocazione
contentissimi non sporcate nulla beh
devo dire che mi devo ricredere
purtroppo il frutto non pensavo anche le
uova si potessero mangiare così alla
grande non ho visto minuti iniziato il
picnic mobile io già chiuso tutto nel
cestino
quindi per me stiamo pure tornare a casa
non senti quella piacevole fitta al
fegato
quindi su stima ancora roba da mangiare
in faccia
basti vedere i cartoni e darle riferito
sempre desiderato fare il db tar è
comunque uscite di emergenza sono venuto
a ovunque
ragazzi ho trovato un nuovo metodo per
mangiare in maniera 6 mascherina in
cambio dei miei
andava bene dice dorate niente sì c'è
tartufo e skipper amore insieme con
grasse nota sgrassa questa grazia e
questo grazie
la prima salsiccia va a guglielmo era
tiro e adesso ti tiro questo tu lo devi
far andare in camera capito che vuol
dire che pargolo mattia parla davanti
alla macchina da presa
ok pronti scappa scappa la guardate di
tirare sull'obiettivo quale come si fa
fateli la faccia marco michael jordan
voglio vedere chi fa la bacco del suo
del rigore ma in realtà una salsiccia un
fiore che se fosse una salsiccia
non ci credo franco e profumo bono pure
questi frutti di bosco e scappa la
promessa nizia pesa sul collo cioè 27
litri che io promuovo questo sistema
allora forse lo lesse forzato di
investigativi stanno facendo sudare il
premio all'impegno henry come ti sembra
questa tecnologia si vede che è fatta da
un mastro artigiano è ogni scatola è
diversa dall'altra c'è alla fine arriva
a lecce avverso talmento perché in più
almeno apprezzando e poi un'altra cosa
cosa si fa e farà amico ma se una
gallina che erano 6 uova thun e mangiate
8 ma posso dire una cosa cosa troviamo
che va a fare nel tuo caso
certo ormai finito
quella street l'utilità è arrivato il
momento di andare a casa e straniero era
pagata diretto quando lo linko sarebbe
per villa 6 indicando una roba sono gli
auguri il re della banda che diego sia
pronto a farlo tu mi facci vedere le tue
doti ma devi correre
abbiamo
terrore
d'accordo
mazza siamo tornati a casa posso dire
una sola parola successo il picnic
mobile si può fare ragazzi io vi dico
prego insomma tu sei devastato io volevo
dire prego a questi ragazzi ma
soprattutto grazie a skipper per aver
creduto aver avuto la lungimiranza
nell'appoggiare questo mio piano che
dire la prossima volta cena su
mongolfiera ok ma la costruiscono la
mongolfiera così siamo sicuri di
rimetterci la vita ragazzi metteteci un
bel pollice in su per favore se ti è
piaciuto questo video lasciateci un
commento scrivendo schippo ambiente
schede a questo canale noi ci vediamo
sempre il martedì con dei blog il
giovedì con un video speciale e domenica
con la cucina
ciao